hey man I'm Kevin Smith and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
a weird question they went to the
internet and literally typed in that
question
who is Kevin Smith who is Kevin Smith I
used to be able to be like Oh Kevin
Smith fat guy from New Jersey but then
that changed Kevin Smith won't stop he's
been at it for 25 years doing various
that's who Kevin Smith is who
is Kevin Smith Big Bang Theory does that
indicate that people were watching The
Big Bang Theory be like I don't know
this fool is I have to look him up
how weird because in my mind everybody
knows Who I am I've been around for 25
years smeared all over the corporate
landscape like feces and I assume most
people know who I am but what this tells
me is her bunch of cats who were
watching that Big Bang figure were like
I don't know who this clot is who is
Kevin Smith daughter really the question
behind the question is who Kevin Smith
to give them a kid I'm sure that's the
next question who on earth would Kevin
Smith Kevin Smith's daughter who's Kevin
Smith's daughter I can answer that
Harley Quinn Smith you named her after
the Joker's sidekick who is Kevin Smith
married to that makes a lot of sense so
right after like who would this fool the
obvious question is who did this pool
this lady if I could ride in here and
say Jennifer Schwalbach
got a name like an old German hausfrau
but she not when I met her she was a
journalist she wrote for USA Today I
gave a really good interview the
interview lasted like an hour but then
we sat around talking for two hours
after that and stuff and she got to know
who is Kevin Smith Kevin Smith Who Wants
to Be a Millionaire
did I win can you win without playing
and did nobody tell me wouldn't that be
amazing if I'd had like a million
dollars unclaimed sitting at ABC for
like the better part of last 10 years
that's like you money right there I have
no idea why this would be maybe there
was a contestant named Kevin Smith I'll
be honest with you the name doesn't
exactly stand out like Quentin
Tarantino's only one of those there are
a lot of Kevin Smith's what was Kevin
Smith first movie clerks that's the word
I say every day of my life and have
since 1994 because it changed my entire
life I made this movie called clerks
that's why we're having this
conversation what happened to Kevin
Smith question you never want to read
while you're out there promote
a movie don't feel real relevant when
you're like what happened Kevin Smith
he's still around
I think I'm gonna choose to believe its
references what happened to Kevin Smith
his health condition because I change I
used to be a larger person now I'm a
smaller person because I had a massive
heart attack so what happened to Kevin
Smith
he had a Widowmaker that's the heart
attack you have when the el-ad was the
artery it goes across the front of your
heart 100% blocked by cholesterol
excites to eat a lot of animal food
products I used to drink two gallons of
milk a day
the doctor goes you got full blockage in
the led going across your heart man
that's called a Widowmaker heart attack
reached up in me and saved my life with
his hands and tools and just like that
that's amazing so what happened to Kevin
Smith
he lived most he's like the Boy Who
Lived he's a modern-day Harry Potter
with none of the magic what is Kevin
Smith diet after I had a heart attack my
kid encouraged me to go vegan she had
been a vegan for two three years at that
point so she was like I gotta flip him
and she did and I became vegan and so I
hate vegetables
can hate him with a passion very hard to
be vegan when you hate vegetables and
stuff but what I do is now I
intermittently fast because given the
choice between like broccoli and
kumquats you're like you know what I'd
rather not eat and so you just don't eat
at all and so you skip meals I don't eat
breakfast I make my fast at about one or
two o'clock in the afternoon so my god
go as deep into the day as I can and I
don't eat before after 8 o'clock at
night because what happened to Kevin
Smith what his chemist with diet is he
went vegan what episodes of the flash
did Kevin Smith direct sometimes in my
spare time when I was sitting around
just talking for a living I direct so
I've directed a few episodes three
episodes of the flash it's a show where
the boy solves all those problems while
running very fast and then I've directed
four episodes of Supergirl and that's a
show in which the girl solves all of her
problems by being from another planet
altogether what does Kevin Smith smell
like tastes like what's the question
gonna be look like now well you're
looking at it it's that simple
this ain't a choice this is like you
know either eat healthy and lose weight
or die so that's what Kevin Smith looks
like now
why is Kevin Smith and Lego Batman 3 so
somebody was playing Lego Batman 3 and
they're like you me he's in this too why
I don't know I got asked I remember
getting a phone call and they're like
you like Batman right I love Batman like
you want to be in the Lego Batman game I
was like yeah because my career started
in film as director but somewhere along
the line I let go of that and I just
became me for a living where is Kevin
Smith
where's Kevin Smith's comic book store
it's in Red Bank New Jersey beautiful
downtown Red Bank New Jersey we had a TV
show about it for seven seasons that's
five into to seven seasons on AMC was
called comic book men which stormtrooper
was Kevin Smith because I played a
stormtrooper in the force awakens man
it's just my voice I wasn't in the
costume I couldn't have squeezed into
the costume at that point he didn't have
a name they didn't give me a designation
I called him TK 420 you know because you
get it could Kevin Smith direct Batman
what a great question if you're asking
me I'd say no that takes patience making
them superhero movies look like they
take a lot of time I barely have enough
patience for the CW shows they shoot
those things in nine days and by day six
I'm like are we still doing this if I
was asked to direct a Batman movie I'm
not dumb I'd say yeah and I'd let
somebody else do it and collect the
check why does Kevin Smith wear hockey
jerseys clearly today that's not the
case for a long long time I lived in
hockey jerseys I was much heavier and
for those of you this don't know this
the hockey jersey also acts as a fat
guys muumuu so I lived in hockey jerseys
to hide my flat then I lost a bunch of
weight and I kept trying to wear the
hockey jersey but I look stupid in them
now I've worn shorts the whole time 25
beers I'm committed to jorts they're
coming back kids get your parent out
goes back so George we'll be back
to our all Kevin Smith movies connected
what a great question most of them are
in the beginning of my career I was real
into the idea of universe building and
so all my movies are connected the
people in clerks reference events and
Mallrats and vice versa the people in
chasing a me know all those characters
Jay and Silent Bob pop up in all the
movies
all the characters in the slow section
of New Jersey everybody knows each other
and stuff like that so now in the age of
Marvel movies people like hey man you
did it before Marvel they stole your
idea they did not I stole that idea from
Marvel Comics like in the comic books
everybody knew each other so when I made
movies I was like I want to do and I
like that I like the notion of like oh
yeah everybody knew each other in this
world why should every story stand apart
and these people don't know each other I
like the idea of crossover as a
comic-book kid that appealed to me so I
put it deep into my movies as well did
Kevin Smith go to college he did for
like a red-hot Minuteman he went to
Community College in Brooke to Ella's
where I live in in jus Jersey when I was
growing up but I tried to go to the New
School for Social Research in Manhattan
it was for writing I wanted to be a
writer real badly I lived on the eighth
floor of a building in Union Square and
I'd only ever lived on one floor my
whole life and one day we're all sitting
around the suite somebody throws a water
balloon out the window and I'm like what
what a great idea man and suddenly we
start making water balloons and whipping
them out the window for like BAM and
throwing them eight floors down everyone
else in the room it got bored of it but
me I was like let's keep doing it so I
go home that weekend my parents said
come in here to the living room and
they're like what is this letter and
they hand me a letter from my college
where they tell my parents that I was
throwing water balloons out my window
and that they've heard that I plan to
repeat this activity at the end of the
school year and they're letting my
parents know if one drop of water hits
the ground in Manhattan they're calming
the NYPD and blaming me and I'm getting
arrested
and I'm like College like this is a high
school tattletale thing they can tell on
you in college
upper education this is a bunch of
this is high school plus so I
dropped out of college man I went to
Brookdale for a few semesters and then
instead I wind up making clerks did
Kevin Smith discover Chris Hemsworth
if anyone's asking then yes I discovered
Chris Hemsworth is in my new movie Jay
and Silent Bob reboot and he was
wonderful in it he came in crushed it he
was funny and dudes very very funny and
insanely easy to look at oh my god does
Kevin Smith like Kevin Bacon
everybody loves Kevin Bacon man does
Kevin Smith
have a podcast come on Kevin Smith has
nothing but podcasts got nothing going
for him he's got a lot of podcasts I
think I got five at this point active
ones SModcast Jay and Silent Bob get old
Hollywood babble-on fat man beyond I
guess poor active ones at this point
does Kevin Smith drink what an
interesting question no I don't and you
want to know why it's because of Jesus
let me tell you about my friend Jesus no
I'm just kidding I don't like the taste
of booze Oh
drinkin not for me I ain't against I
don't sound try to tell people be
teetotalers and don't drink but I can't
stand it it's not for me at all weed on
the other hand is Kevin Smith Silent Bob
you just saw it absolutely he is it is
Kevin Smith Canadian what a great
question I get this ask this all the
time and people assume I am because I
wore the hockey jerseys I made a movie
called Dogma in which God was portrayed
by Alanis Morissette because I always
felt that God would be Canadian so a lot
of people assume that I'm Canadian I'm
not I'm from New Jersey I'm just a
Canada file if I could be a dual citizen
I almost did I came close to taking the
test and becoming a dual citizen just
for the of it not like as I married
somebody cuz I was like I'd be proud to
be Canadian till somebody's like you're
gonna be paying income taxes in two
different countries I was like wait what
and then I backed off I like Canada but
I don't want them taking all my money is
Kevin Smith religious he made a movie
called Dogma he was raised religious
Kevin Smith I like when we talk about
him in the third person is he religious
now no I guess I would describe him as
spiritual he believes in people dogma
might have been the last gasp of my my
religious background that was me kind of
working my stuff out and going like oh I
guess I guess I'm done with this is
Kevin Smith a good director Kevin Smith
is my favorite director in the world the
movies he makes are exactly the movies
that I want to see every aspect of him
I'm like oh my god he got it right good
director he's a great director now you
asked others not necessarily the case so
that's it man
those are all the questions that have
been googled about me ever so nobody
ever needs to Google me again we've
covered that area like I've done Google
a service you're welcome Google now you
could concentrate on more important
matters but we've covered Kevin Smith to
death
near death